con música pancartas y trajes
tradicionales miles de Seguidores del
presidente Gustavo Petro salieron a las
calles para dejar constancia de que los
deseos de cambio en Colombia siguen
intactos
con el respaldo popular Gustavo Petro
aprovechó para instar al congreso a la
aprobación de sus reformas sociales
con peto
le solicitamos
de nuestra propia humildad
le solicitamos desde nuestras ganas de
justicia y de paz
que aprueben las reformas que le
garantizan al pueblo colombiano sus
derechos
contigo la movilización que en principio
era para respaldar las reformas se tornó
en favor del proyecto político de Petro
afectado recientemente por el escándalo
de escuchas ilegales que provocaron la
salida de su jefa de gabinete y del
embajador de Colombia en Venezuela en su
alocución Petro volvió a manifestarse en
contra de la interceptación de
comunicaciones de manera ilegal noche
usamos magistrados no usamos periodistas
no chozamos gente de la oposición no
violamos los derechos de la humanidad en
el territorio colombiano el jefe de
estado reiteró que para el segundo
semestre del año espera por poner dos
nuevas reformas dirigidas a mejorar la
educación y los servicios públicos